ein impfstoff ändert alles wenn er kommt
und wenn er wirkt dann ist der korona
albtraum vermutlich irgendwann vorbei
bis dahin ist es noch ein bitterer weg
was wir im kampf gegen die pandemie
brauchen wird knapp klinikbetten tests
und geduld wie gehen wir mit dieser
knappheit eigentlich um erst recht wenn
es von den retten den impfstoffen auch
erst einmal nicht genug geben wird wir
müssen reden mit diesen gästen malu
dreyer
die ministerpräsidentin von rheinland
pfalz sagt diese zweite corona welle
trifft uns mit voller wucht
michael kretschmer der sächsische
ministerpräsident stellt fest
leider nehmen viele das virus immer noch
nicht ernst
stefan kluge der intensivmediziner aus
hamburg warnt die anzahl der
intensivpatienten wird in den nächsten
zehn tagen stark steigen
peter kremsner leitet die klinische
studie mit dem impfstoff der firma pure
weg und sagt bis februar wird es einen
impfstoff geben
alena büchs die vorsitzende des
deutschen ethikrats sagt wer ein hohes
krankheitsrisiko hat muss zuerst geimpft
werden
und jonas schmidt chanasit der geologe
weiß auch mit einem impfstoff wird das
virus teil unseres lebens bleiben
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und
die begrüßte alle gäste natürlich sehr
herzlich egal ob zugeschaltet oder im
studio liebe zuschauer das war die
nachricht der woche dem corona virus
soll es demnächst an den kragen gehen
auf diesen impfstoff liegen große
hoffnungen
90% wirksamkeit meldet der hersteller
piontek aus mainz ein versprechen das
experten geradezu elektrisiert wir haben
alle große hoffnungen in diesen
impfstoff und das zurecht wir sehen
erste lichter dass wir 20 21 auch
riesige schritte machen werden die
pandemie zu besiegen
angela merkels corona strategie beruht
auf einem impfstoff nur mit ihm kann
ihre vision vom ende der pandemie war
werden
ich bin sicher das leben wie wir es
kannten wird zurückkehren
die familien werden wieder feiern die
clubs und theater und fußball stadien
wieder voll sein und was für eine freude
wird das dann
[Musik]
noch aber ist der impfstoff nicht
zugelassen er kann auch scheitern viele
fragen sind noch offen wir wissen
überhaupt nicht ob dieser impfstoff
jetzt zum beispiel vor der infektion
schützt oder vor der erkrankung schützt
diese daten liegen noch gar nicht vor
bisher hat der hersteller biontech keine
studien veröffentlicht nur eine
pressemitteilung das hat vor allem die
börse gefreut
und noch ein haken auch mit einem
impfstoff werden einschränkungen weiter
nötig seien aber zum ersten mal seit
langem gibt es hoffnung könnte der spuk
bald vorbei sein
jonas schmidt chanasit ist bei uns vom
bernhard-nocht-institut in hamburg mit
china sieht noch sind viele fragen offen
aber dürfen sich die menschen einfach
erstmal freuen ja natürlich darf man
sich das wollen das ist doch das erste
mal dass man auch weiß dass so ein m rna
im stoff prinzipiell wirksamkeit zeigen
kann und das ist ein großer schritt nach
vorne nichts desto trotz entbindet uns
das überhaupt nicht von der aufgabe über
eine langfristige nachhaltige strategie
nachzudenken wo der impfstoff erst mal
nur ein baustein sein wird und eben
nicht in den nächsten monaten das ende
dieser pandemie einläutet das ist ganz
klar
sie haben immer gesagt herr schmidt
chanasit wir werden mit diesem virus
leben lernen müssen wäre das mit dem
impfstoff dann eigentlich überhaupt noch
nötig das virus werden wir so wie es
jetzt erst mal aussieht natürlich nicht
ihr reduzieren können aber wir werden
natürlich viel besser damit leben können
umgehen können wenn wir ein großteil der
menschen vor infektionen schützen können
und das ist ja das entscheidende aber es
rollten können und bei uns ist an all
die alena büchs zugeschaltet aus mainz
dieses mal die chefin des deutschen
ethikrates frau box warum treten so
viele jetzt schon wieder auf die
euphoriebremse
also erstmal glaube ich sollte man schon
sagen dass das ein ganz ermutigender tag
war an dem diese nachricht kam die mich
irgendwie bringen auch sehr überrascht
hat aber als wissenschaftlerin denkt man
sich natürlich man möchte jetzt erstmal
diese daten genau anschauen da sind auch
noch fragen offen also wie lange schützt
der denn die menschen davor dass sie
sich anstecken können und das zweite
problem ist eben dass wir ganz sicher am
anfang nicht genug haben werden für all
diejenigen die sich gerne impfen lassen
würden
und das heißt wir brauchen eine
priorisierung auf zeit und darüber
werden wir noch reden bei uns ist malu
dreyer die ministerpräsidentin von
rheinland-pfalz frau dreyer wird die
ankündigung die menschen tatsächlich
wieder mit mut ausstatten und mit
zuversicht oder wird der leichtsinn
wachsen was denken sie nein ich glaube
tatsächlich dass einfach ein sehr
schöner tag war für viele menschen auch
wieder etwas hoffnung einfach da war
denn man fragt sich ja schon als ganz
normaler bürger und mensch geht es jetzt
immer so weiter und insofern war das ein
toller tag für mich war es ein doppelt
toller tag weil ich natürlich als
ministerpräsidentin wahnsinnig
darauf bin ich in mainz und das sind
tolle wissenschaftler an der spitze des
unternehmens die ja auch mir schon lange
bekannt sind durch die
universitätsmedizin und ihrer forschung
und dass sie den mut hatten auch eine
ausgründung zu machen und jetzt auf den
weg erfolgreich sind es freut mich
natürlich in doppelter hinsicht werden
bei uns ist michael kretschmer
zugeschaltet aus leipzig weil in
häuslicher quarantäne und deshalb via
skype herr kretschmann manche sagen
einen impfstoff ändert alles auch für
die politik oder erstmal nicht also ich
freue mich auch erst mal über das
ergebnis wir haben als deutschland mit
unseren wissenschaftlern den test
hergestellten dem man dieses virus
nachweisen kann und jetzt auch einen
impfstoff
das zeigt die stärke dieses landes die
hervorragende wissenschaft und natürlich
setzen wir darauf dass so wie bei
anderen kranken auch bei der saisonalen
grippe oder bei massa der medizinische
fortschritt also impfung uns das leben
mit diesem virus erreicht hat deswegen
ist das eine tolle nachricht
stefan kluge zugeschaltet aus hamburg
herr kluge sie sind der leiter der
intensivmedizin am uniklinikum in
hamburg eppendorf biontech sagt nun
seine impfung schütze und habe keine
bedeutsamen nebenwirkungen
dann werden wir eigentlich wissen ob das
auch so stimmt ja man muss sicherlich
aber auch so ein bisschen vorsichtig
sein die studie ist ja noch gar nicht
beendet die studie ist noch gar nicht
publiziert bei 90 prozent ist immer der
mediziner so ein bisschen vorsichtig das
sind sehr euphorische daten aber wir
müssen glaube ich sehr vorsichtig diese
daten auch uns anschauen die sache
prüfen
denn das hat ja eine riesen relevanz und
auch das thema sicherheit und
nebenwirkung von impfen ist ja extrem
entscheidend auch für die impf
motivation der bundesbürger also da sind
noch viele fragen offen aber natürlich
ist das erstmal ein positives signal
arzt und apotheker werden also
hoffentlich in ein paar wochen
verlässlich über nebenwirkungen
informieren können
wir sind in tübingen verbunden mit
professor peter kremsner er begleitet
die forschung der firma care weg an
einem corona impfstoff herr grenzen auch
wenn der weg mitbewerber ist sie freuen
sich auch für die mainzer
auf jeden fall wir freuen uns sehr das
ist eine großartige nachricht die uns
alle aufhorchen ließ das ist so früh
kommt war auch für mich eine
überraschung ich habe es erhofft und es
ist jetzt eingetroffen und wir sind
jetzt auch überzeugt dass es
funktionieren wird und auch mit dem
impfstoff den wir jetzt testen wo wir
demnächst die phase 3 beginnen werden
das sieht sehr gut aus dass es jetzt
nicht nur mit diesem einen sondern auch
mit mehreren anderen unter anderem neben
dem kurpark impfstoff klappen wird
klappen könnte und klappen wird sagte er
sogar
wodurch werden sich diese impfstoffe
unterscheiden herr kanzler
ja es gibt sehr viele unterschiedliche
ansätze mit wirkstoffen die einen haben
virus vektoren die anderen sind
schlichte eiweißmoleküle unterschiedlich
mit hilfsstoffen versetzt und dann gibt
es auch noch die nukleinsäure basierten
impfstoff mit dna und rna impfstoffe und
einiges mehr
diese bisherigen sind ja diese
impfstoffe wie sie eben in tübingen und
mainz nun erforscht werden und
hergestellt werden die hat es noch nie
gegeben woher kommt eigentlich über in
ihre überzeugung dass die sicher sind
die daten die wir bisher haben zeigen
dass also ich kann die die wir hier
generiert haben das sind über 280
impflinge die wir bereits haben genau
einsehen da sehen wir dass es keine
schweren schwerwiegende unerwünschte
nebenwirkungen gibt das stimmt uns sehr
zuversichtlich und das gleiche habe ich
jetzt auch durch die pressemitteilung
gehört von dem biontech impfstoff auch
das ist eigentlich großartig dass es
keine einzige schwerwiegende
nebenwirkungen also wahrscheinlich mit
dem impfstoff in zusammenhang gebracht
gibt und das zeigt dass es funktioniert
dass die impfung verträglich ist und
dass sie jetzt noch dazu auch wirksam
ist
der impfstoff von beyond es bei minus 70
grad gelagert werden beansprucht dass
ihr impfstoff auch das wird erst mal so
sein das ist auch hier so das sind
letztlich vorkehrungen die wir getroffen
haben das ist durch diesen
zulassungsprozess bedingt aber
grundsätzlich ist es so dass mit diesen
impfstoffen eine große temperaturen
empfindlichkeit herrscht die kann man
eigentlich auch ja auf dem küchentisch
in den tropen aufheben und da sind sie
immer noch stabil und das wird auch so
kommen dass sie bei raumtemperatur
irgendwann gelagert werden aber nicht in
der für die erste zulassung und nicht in
der ersten zeit
nun ist das alles das macht sich der
zuschauer auch aus natürlich eine
industrie es ist auch ein
milliardengeschäft für welchen impfstoff
sollte der staat geld ausgeben und wie
viel
ja das ist eine schwierige frage für
mich grundsätzlich ist es so dass wir
uns freuen dass wissenschaftler und
ärzte dass die forschung gefördert wird
und dass es jetzt so gut geklappt hat
und auch relativ unbürokratisch geklappt
hat dass wir so große forschungs mengen
und auch die firmen forschungsgelder
bekommen haben das ist einzigartig und
auch die zusammenarbeit mit den
zulassungsbehörden und den
ethikkommissionen all das funktioniert
wie man sich das nur erträumen lassen
konnte vorher
man kann jetzt nicht sagen man sollte
diesen impfstoff oder anderen besonders
bevorzugen in deutschland sind natürlich
jetzt vor allem die in deutschland
produzierten und entwickelten impfstoffe
vorrangig gefördert worden
und das ist jetzt auch normal und in der
eu werden die auch dann vorrangig
eingekauft soweit ich das weiß
werden wir noch später drüber reden
einer nachricht hat hier viele menschen
verunsichert grenzen in dänemark sind
mutationen des virus bei erzen und auch
beim menschen entdeckt worden
besteht die gefahr im schlimmsten fall
dass die in forschung noch mal
bei null anfangen muss im schlimmsten
fall ist das so aber ich sehe das im
moment nicht als beunruhigend an diese
daten kenne ich natürlich auch aber bis
vor etwa zwei wochen ich glaube da haben
wir die hundertste mutation des corolla
virus 2 gefeiert also es geht bunt
weiter die viren mutieren und es wird
neue mutationen geben ob die relevant
sind ob das solche sind die besonders
davor kommend wo es schmerzt und ob es
dann änderungen in der krankmachenden
wirkung der viren gibt ob es dann
unterschiede in der vermehrungsfähigen
der infektiosität gibt all das wird man
sehen im moment schaut das nicht danach
aus mit welcher sorge schauen sie
eigentlich auf die zahlen des rk ii wir
schauen uns das natürlich auch immer
wieder an und gerade für ganz europa
auch für die ganze welt mit sorge
erfüllt mich die ganze entwicklung in
der europäischen union im moment das ist
eher traurig aber ich hoffe durch die
maßnahmen wird sich das jetzt
abschwächen was mich erstaunt ist die
entwicklung im tropischen afrika wo das
kogit 19 fasst er verschwindet was auch
bemerkenswert ist sich noch niemand so
richtig erklären kann dann zu nehmen
müssen
danke für ihre expertise heute abend
danke nach tübingen und wir sind in der
runde
herr schmidt chanasit diesen impfstoff
von bieren tag wird eine wirksamkeit von
90 prozent zugeschrieben
wer man nicht hierzulande auch mit einem
60 prozentigen impfstoff schon mal sehr
zufrieden natürlich und das ist ja auch
die zielvorgabe der wiro und der anderen
organisationen ja genau und insofern ist
das erst mal wenn man diese 90 prozent
liest natürlich eine absolut unerwartet
positive nachricht und das was herr
kremsler eben gesagt hat müssen jetzt in
die details schauen wenn die auch
offengelegt werden welche altersgruppen
betrifft das vieh langanhaltend ist der
schutz sind dass antikörper positive
antikörper negative
da haben wir bei anderen impfstoffen
auch schon überraschungen erlebt und das
kann hier natürlich auch der fall sein
so
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir auf diese
warten warten bei nur dann kann man
natürlich auch eine maßgeschneiderte
impfstrategie festlegen das hängt an
diesen daten die noch nicht vorliegen
die wir alle noch nicht hatten frau
büchs es handelt sich in jedem fall um
ein lebenswichtiges gut wenn es einen
solchen impfstoff oder mehrere
impfstoffe gibt wie viel geld kann man
dafür ausgeben ist es eigentlich
unbezahlt das ist eine ganz schwierige
frage
ich weiß dass viele der unternehmen
vorhaben das nicht sozusagen normalen
markt preisen anzubieten sondern darum
zu gehen und das halte ich für sehr klug
denn was natürlich nicht passieren darf
ist dass jetzt die unterschiedlichen
länder in so einen bieterwettkampf
beraten und der preis einfach durch die
decke geht da muss man sagen erwartet
man sich jetzt auch natürlich von der
industrie die ja sehr stark auch
gefördert wurde die viele mittel
erhalten hat dass das auch als einen
beitrag letztlich nicht nur zum
allgemeingut sondern zum welt gut
darstellt der nur wir wir alle als ganze
welt kommen nur aus dieser pandemie
heraus wenn wir gute wege finden und
impfstoffe sind eben ein wichtiger weg
und ich glaube da sollte man bei der
bepreisung zurückhaltend sein
herr kretschmann der bund kaufte wir
wandern wieder nach berlin und nach
deutschland der bund kauft die
bundeswehr lagert und dann werden auch
noch impfzentren aufgebaut bei der
logistik kann jetzt nichts mehr
schiefgehen
seine herausforderung ich hier haben wir
in jedem landkreis jetzt vorgesehen so
ein impfzentrum und das braucht logistik
wir haben wir gehört 70 grad - der
impfstoff gelagert werden das nicht
einfach aber die erwartungen sind groß
und ich freue mich darauf weil ich auch
wenn diesen technologischen diesen
medizinischen fortschritt glaube und
deswegen treffen alle länder jetzt die
voraussetzung dafür dass das dann auch
schnell gehen können wir gucken von den
bundesländern vor drei jahren noch mal
auf die verteilung in der welt da gibt
es viele initiativen dass das fair
geschieht ist von frau wuchs schon
erwähnt werden auch von herrn kremsner
denken sie dass das gelingen
oder ist am ende erst recht wenn es sich
um ein knappes gut handelt am anfang
dann doch jedes land erst mal nur bei
sich und schaut auf sich das ist die
große herausforderung finde ich der
weltpolitik also man hat es ja im moment
in europa schon ganz gut organisiert das
finde ich auch sehr sehr gut dass man
sich einig ist dass man tatsächlich
europäisch vorgeht und wir müssen in
deutschland natürlich auch dafür sorgen
dass der impfstoff dann der hier ist
dass das kein windhundrennen gibt
sondern dass wir uns wirklich auf gute
kriterien verständigen dass auch der
preis nicht die rolle spielen kann das
jeder mensch diesen impfstoff auch
erhalten kann unabhängig davon wie er
versichert ist das heißt von groß bis
ganz klar bis nach ganz unten müssen wir
faire regeln haben aber ich glaube dass
das gelingen kann und die pharma sind ja
auch eigentlich ganz gut aufgestellt
also sie haben ja auch die konzerne sind
teilweise auch selbst so aufgestellt
dass sie den amerikanischen markt
beliefern die anderen europäischen markt
beliefern und wenn es diese einigkeit
gibt in europa was man wirklich
gemeinsam vorgehen will dann finde ich
das absolut begrüßenswert und ich glaube
auch dass wir es in deutschland gut
schaffen können nach fairen kriterien
die uns ja teilweise auch vorgeschlagen
worden sind dann auch den impfstoff so
zu verteilen dass jeder davon dann auch
profitieren da ist es schon erwähnt die
stiko die ständige impfkommission hat
ein papier erarbeitet für die
reihenfolge in der geimpft werden kann
eben weil am anfang nicht genug im
vakzine da sein werden
zusammen mit der leopoldina und dem
deutschen ethikrat geht es also um eine
priorisierung so könnte die aus
zuerst sollten risikopatienten geimpft
werden zum beispiel menschen in alten
und pflegeheimen sie sterben besonders
häufig wenn sie sich infizieren
als zweites medizinisches personal
ärztinnen und ärzte pflegerinnen und
pfleger denn sie dürfen sich nicht
anstecken und ausfallen
ebenfalls priorisiert polizisten lehrer
feuerwehrleute menschen in
systemrelevanten berufen frau box wie
weiß man eigentlich ob man berechtigt
ist und wer überwacht dass man stellt
sich ja sofort vor dass jeder nach der
poleposition strebt wie weiß man ob man
berechtigt ist und muss man das
kontrollieren also das wissen wir auch
noch nicht wir haben jetzt in diesem
gemeinsamen papier die rahmenbedingungen
ausformuliert also die ethischen
kriterien nachdem man das möglichst
gerecht verteilen kann
aber die feinkörnige berechnungen der
subgruppen also wer hat wirklich die
höchsten risiken wäre es am stärksten
gefährdet und wer gefährdet vielleicht
auch am stärksten andere das muss erst
tatsächlich noch erfolgen da gibt es
also dann noch eine weitere
impfempfehlung ja auch das hänge auch
das hängt natürlich davon ab was die
einzelnen impfstoffe leisten das ist
völlig klar dass mit china sieht es gibt
die idee das fand ich interessant
jüngere zuerst zu impfen
weil die durch ihre mobilität natürlich
das virus weiter verbreiten als dass ein
älterer mensch gegebenenfalls tut ist
auch an der sache nicht eigentlich dran
das ist eine idee wenn es eben um die
impfung auf bevölkerungs ebene geht um
eben ein hohes maß an immunität zu
erreichen das ist aber eine andere frage
die sich bei den risikogruppen stellt
und bei den ärzten und pflegerinnen die
sozusagen einem sehr hohen
infektionsrisiko ausgesetzt sind und
hier kann man ja sagen da gibt es schon
daten bei den m rna impfstoffen das
überhaupt auch in die risikogruppen
gehen können bei anderen impfstoffen
hört dass nämlich bei 55 jahren auf und
dann erreichen wir gar nicht die
menschen besonders nötig haben weil die
bei anderen impfstoffen zum beispiel
nicht so gut auf eine impfung reagieren
also genau das gilt es zu
berücksichtigen dass frau brooke auch
gesagt hat und so lange muss man eben
warten sonst kann man das leben nicht
konkret machen
herr kluge jens spahn der
gesundheitsminister in bezug auf die
risikogruppen gesagt dass sein
eigentlich 40 prozent der bevölkerung
dann müsste man so eine aufteilung nicht
nachdenken die wäre keine besondere
hilfe oder naja ich denke wir wissen
dass vor allem die älteren patienten
einen schweren verlauf haben wir wissen
dass ab 50 grad ab 60 das risiko
deutlich steigt und eine über 80 jährige
hat ein risiko von über 10% im
krankenhaus zu versterben wenn er dann
corona virus positiv ist also ich denke
schon die älteren mit schweren
vorerkrankungen das macht schon sinn
dass man diese gruppe zuerst einem stoff
einem wirkstoff anbietet das macht schon
sinn
ärzte und pfleger sollen möglichst
schnell geimpft werden auch sie sind
logischerweise priorisiert erst recht
weil sie sich auch selber anstecken
können rechnen sie eigentlich für auch
ihr personal für ihre kollegen mit einer
art impfpflicht
davon würde ich nicht ausgehen in
deutschland haben wir doch sind wir sehr
weit entfernt von dieser impfpflicht ich
persönlich würde gut mit leben können
aber ich glaube da ist die gesetze
gesellschaft nicht dazu bereit wir sehen
ja selbst beim krankenhauspersonal bei
der jährlichen grippeimpfung dass nur 60
prozent mit einem maximalen aufwand sich
impfen lassen und die sind alle am
patienten
also das ist glaube ich sehr schwierig
und das würde auch keine breite
akzeptanz stoßen
ich denke schon dass ich viele impfen
lassen würden aber die quote liegt auch
im krankenhaus sicherlich nicht bei 90
oder 100 prozent
es ist hochinteressant stücks insgesamt
sagen 60 prozent der deutschen in einer
jüngsten umfrage dass sie sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen nicht gegen cupid
19 impfen lassen wollen oder noch nicht
was macht man mit menschen die das nicht
also das ist eine der großen
herausforderung aber man muss auch sagen
dass vor zwei wochen die daten anders
aussahen also das schwankt im moment
ganz intensiv offensichtlich treibt das
die leute um unter verändern sich
einstellungen und ich bin relativ
zuversichtlich dass sich das auch wieder
positiv verändert denn das ist einfach
ein weg wie man diese ganze katastrophe
hinter sich wird lassen können und ich
glaube das wird für sehr viele menschen
doch sehr attraktiv sein und ich gehe
davon aus wenn wir jetzt gut erklären
wie das alles funktioniert gut erklären
dass auch niemand an dieser
priorisierung sie wie vor bei schummeln
kann und einfach immer wieder dann ernst
nehmen dass die menschen wissen wollen
das ist sicher und das funktioniert ich
bin relativ zuversichtlich dass wir dann
ganz gute im fragen kriegen klar bei der
sicherheit 3er dafür aber keinen rabatt
geben also das muss ein sicherer im
stoff sein auch wenn sie sich jetzt
freuen final aber absolut also davon
gehe ich aber auch aus ich bin jetzt
keine wissenschaftlerin aber was ich
erlebe das habe ich auch als
gesundheitspolitikerin früher noch nie
erlebt nämlich das wirklich die ganze
welt zusammenarbeitet das
zulassungsbehörden so flexibel sind in
wien nun an jeden vor dass man
einreichen kann die unterlagen wirklich
mit der forschung und dass jeder einfach
darauf bedacht ist sehr schnell zu
ergebnissen zu kommen aber nicht eben
leicht fertig sondern die studien werden
ja genauso erforderlich sein und ich
will vielleicht noch 12 impfpflicht oder
zur überzeugung sagen also ich bin auch
absolut gegen eine pflicht aber ich bin
auch davon überzeugt wenn einmal die
transparenz da ist wenn man klar ist die
studien sind ausgebreitet wofür wirkt es
was sind nebenwirkungen was sind sie
nicht dass man dann wirklich auch werben
kann und das ganz offensiv sein kann und
das dann auch die überzeugung wachsen
wird wenn die antworten überzeugend sind